welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B and today we're talking about
the world's most fearsome fighting teens
that's right we are breaking down the
first trailer for Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Mutant Mayhem title after my own
heart as a master of alliteration this
new animated entry into the franchise is
brought To Us by Superbad super
producers Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg
and after this trailer I am so psyched
to see it on opening day August 4th as a
kid I was a massive Turtles fan I had
all the toys clothes and I even saw the
original live-action movies in theaters
as an adult I was introduced to the
original grittier comics from Kevin
Eastman Peter Laird this movie seems
like a new chapter and feel for the
franchise and I'm here for it let's get
into the trailer we start off with a
teaser to the teaser with a seven second
Montage of the turtles surfing down a
string of lights rock steady and Bebop
Rock and steady and Bebop into the music
and April O'Neill showing a pizza and a
chat with the turtles all of this is set
to the iconic Queens New York City rap
group A Tribe Called Quest classic song
cannot kick it yes you can karate kick
Ninja Kick whatever the trailer starts
off with the Paramount logo a
Nickelodeon logo who's a fight and we
get this incredibly detailed drawing of
NYC I gotta say I love this animation
style already it feels like the
spider-verse animation mixed with a
really unique style of Mitchells versus
the machines we see great sights and
sounds of New York a woman walks her dog
in front of the laundry mat a yellow
taxi cab Rolls by an iconic bridge is
backed up with traffic and nothing says
New York like a traffic jam but this is
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles baby the
action is coming from the sewers the
turtles burst out fly up into the
rooftop where we find out that like all
teenagers these Turtles are content
creators Michelangelo played by the shy
Shimon Brown Jr tosses a watermelon up
to Leonardo Nicholas Cantu from The
fablemans Who slices it with his sword
Donatello voiced by Nickelodeon star
Micah Abby is filming the whole thing it
does make sense that the guy who does
machines would be the camera guy for
these videos one detail I love in the
animation is that they give Donnie a
pair of headphones around his neck a
2023 version of Donatello makes perfect
sense it'd be covered in gear a real
gear guy Rapha outplayed by Brady unit
is initially impressed but come on he's
wrath he's going to want to kick it up a
notch and does just so by suggesting
they try the stunt again but this time
with ninja stars I've always said ninja
stars make everything better even my
grandma's funeral miss you Mima watching
something you love is self-care feels
good right well with geology you have a
good feeling of self-care in your daily
routine too this is it baby geology is a
16-time award-winning personalized skin
care company recognized in men's health
Esquire and ask men grooming Awards with
over 6 000 five-star reviews just take a
quick 30 second diagnostic quiz and
geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you with ingredients
that are dermatologist tested proven to
work and personalized to your needs for
Hair Care geology's got strengthening
shampoo and conditioner and co-wash
which will transform your routine and
deliver the best hair of your life it
extends the time between washes and
replaces the need for so many products
so you wash your hair less and save
money money that sounds good to me they
also offer body washes and deodorants
that are free of harsh ingredients and
smell great for skin care they have you
covered from all angles fight acne
reduce oiliness prevent wrinkles combat
darker puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
aging we're targeting you their daily
personalized skin care routine comes
with too face washes morning face cream
retinol night cream and eye cream right
now for a limited time you can get a
five piece trial set for only 15 if you
use code Rockstar 70 at checkout that's
over 50 worth of product for just 15 on
top of that you get an additional bonus
offer of one of their new skin hair or
body products of your choice when you
add it to your trial to get started just
click the link in the description we've
got a real William Tell situation with
Mikey holding a watermelon that's been
suspiciously painted to look just like
his head over his actual head raft
chastises him well Donnie who I just
realized is sporting thick prescription
glasses assures him that he's fine wrath
fires a star hits his Mark a little too
well in the afternoon is heard with car
alarms and dogs barking down below where
the stars fell we get a great frame of
all four turtles reacting in court of
their personalities Mikey is confused
Donnie looks scared Leo's a bit
frustrated Raphael is so so proud of
himself amidst the audio Carnage down
below Mikey suggests they get out of
there and grab some pizza good to know
some things never change in the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Universe we then
get this really cool Montage of the
turtles and their weapons Donatello and
his bow staff Leonardo and his katanas
Michelangelo and his nunchucks and of
course Rafael and his pair of Psy and
holy smokes there's a mulleted splinter
with his walking stick the trailer
confirmed Splinter will be voiced by
martial arts film Legend Jackie Chan
hell yes the next sequence tells us this
film is a reboot origin story as the
criminals of New York do not yet know
who the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles are
hilariously they compare them to little
Shreks there's a glimpse of Bebop and
Rocksteady voiced by Seth Rogen and John
Cena respectively interestingly
Rocksteady was played by fellow WWE
Superstar Sheamus in the 2016 Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movie Out of the
Shadows it was actually a long history
of pro wrestling and Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles crossover over the years
there have been many Turtle themed pro
wrestlers a little off-brand maybe
copyright infringement and of course WWE
Hall of Famer Kevin Nash played Super
shredder in the 1991 live action film
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles the secret
of the use we also get our first glimpse
of April O'Neil who will be voiced by
the bearer breakout star AO edibiri and
speaking of breakout Stars we want to
give a quick shout out to nerd riot.shop
and the new way collection celebrating
season three of the Mandalorian there
are a bunch of really cool designs
including the one I'm wearing and with
each shirt you have the option to
purchase a shout out that could be read
by Eric or i on an upcoming Wikileaks
episode head on over to nerdrive.shop
and get you one of these the turtles are
in action but these are far from the
heroes in the half shell they are
destined to become their techniques are
sloppy even dangerous as evidenced by
Raphael accidentally chucking aside to
Donnie SNY animation note here I love
all the motion lines used in the
animation in this trailer the line
surrounding the side really reminded me
of both something we'd see in anime but
also in the 2D comic books all this
leads to an title card reveal and this
very cool movie logo we see the turtles
being interviewed by a young April
O'Neil at a place called The Laird which
is a nod to one of the turtle's creators
Peter Laird the turtles are chowing down
on pizza and clarifying that they were
transformed by ooze not goo and yes
fellas I agree it sounds way better ooze
ooze now I want to talk about April
O'Neil for a second because her
character design caused quite an uproar
for chronically online people yesterday
in the original Eastman and Laird Comics
April was drawn as a mixed-raced woman
and Eastman had said he based the
character on his first wife April Fisher
who was herself a mixed race woman all
this to say in Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle Mutant Mayhem April is clearly a
young teenage girl who happens to be a
person of color she's not meant to be
fetishized and her character might just
be a cool helpful Ally to the turtle so
maybe just relax a bit don't add me in
the comments the ones that are already
gonna add me in the comments you're
probably blocked right at 150 we get a
card with all of the voice talent and
holy smokes this cast is absolutely
loaded we've got Giancarlo Esposito as
scientists turn Giant in say Dr Stockman
a standout of the video game for me Rose
Byrne is playing Leatherhead a mutated
alligator we have Hannibal Burris as
Genghis frog from the punk frog TV
spin-off that featured Shredder training
four mutated frogs that he named after
conqueror so there was Napoleon
oh man what was his name they all had
great names Google them if you want to
know post Malone is swimming in his
manta ray Ally Ray filet from the comics
an ice cube is playing Superfly who
based on a little bit of research I
think is an original character or an
amalgamation of a couple characters but
wait there's more my Rudolph is playing
a character named Cynthia utram the
uterums are an alien species and various
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle universes
their species name is pronounced ooh
Trump a lot of ooze themes in the Ninja
Turtles in most continuities they are
responsible for creating the mutagen
that mutates several individuals most
notably the Turtles and Splinter they're
also usually the species that crang is
part of could this mean we are getting a
female crane this might be better on
Rogue Theory but come on Maya Rudolph is
a female crane give it to me I know what
you're thinking there can't possibly be
more this is insane stop it Tommy this
is way too much well guess what it's the
turtles and this movie is jam-packed
also lending their voices to the cast
are Paul freaking Rudd as Mondo Gekko
and what we do in the shadow star
Natasia de matrero who is appropriately
playing wing nut a mutant bat Frenemy of
the turtles now wing God has appeared in
the comics TV series and video games but
the character is a sometimes friend and
sometimes faux to the guys in green who
knows who shall be in this one now the
current cast doesn't list anyone voicing
Shredder I'm available or franchise
favorite Casey Jones I'm also available
but my guess is that this is the
beginning of a franchise and we will be
hearing from those guys soon there you
have it a new batch of Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles has hatched and it seems
like this movie is set to be an
action-packed sometimes silly frequently
hilarious relaunch to the franchise I
love that the turtles sound like actual
teenagers and I think the mutant voice
casting is especially inspired that's it
for now follow me at Tommy bechtold
follow new rockstars and please don't
forget to like And subscribe for Turtle
Talk and much much more cowabunga
[Music]
foreign